[music]
Christopher Gaffari:
The monkeys! They're coming!
Jeffrey Kuperman:
The monkeys are coming.
Gabriel Crouse:
Hi, and welcome to the set of "The Monkeys
Are Coming!" being staged here in the Matthews Acting Studio
Gabriel Crouse:
in the Lewis Center for the Arts. I am Gabriel Crouse, and I
will be directing this unique piece of theater for my senior thesis.
Gabriel Crouse:
OK, Catherine, when you guys come in, actually
by going from extreme cold to warmth, it is
Gabriel Crouse:
an uncomfortable experience.
Catherine Cohen:
OK.
Gabriel Crouse:
In the same way, I think going from the strange
world outside of "snow storm" into "safe room"
Gabriel Crouse:
is an uncomfortable experience, because although
this room is safe, it is very odd -- it is difficult to understand.
Jeffrey Kuperman:
Here's something for your meat pies.
Crowd:
[scream] Wow, did you see that?
Jeffrey Kuperman:
And go get 'em.
Crowd:
Ah!
Gabriel Crouse:
A young Russian firebrand named Lev Lunts
wrote this play in 1920. Because of Soviet
Gabriel Crouse:
oppression, it never got put on stage, so
I'm incredibly excited to be bringing it into
Gabriel Crouse:
a theater for the very first time and channeling
the youthful, hectic and ambitious energy
Gabriel Crouse:
that he infused in this piece.
One of my favorite things about this play
is that Lunts will take a character and plonk
Gabriel Crouse:
him on the stage and then give him absolutely
nothing to say or do for 20 minutes.
Gabriel Crouse:
That leaves an incredible space for the actor to
innovate and discover what that character
Gabriel Crouse:
should be saying, who they should be saying
it to, and why they're doing what they're doing.
Gabriel Crouse:
Watching each actor individually trace out
their personal journeys has been one of the
Gabriel Crouse:
most fruitful parts of the rehearsal process
and continues to be one of the most delightful
Gabriel Crouse:
experiences I've ever had in theater.
Jeffrey Kuperman:
Ladies and gentlemen, I am a Shoot. I'm a
very good Shoot, don't you think?
Gabriel Crouse:
"The Monkeys Are Coming" opens on Sept. 30
in the Matthews Acting Studio and closes on Oct. 8.
Gabriel Crouse:
Come check out this play. It's hilarious,
it's horrifying and sometimes just plain odd.
Christopher Ghaffari:
The monkeys are coming!
Crowd:
[screams]
[music]